Cette vidéo est destinée très spécifiquement,
comme son titre l’indique,
aux élèves de Prépa HEC.
Et étant donné que j’échange beaucoup,
depuis plusieurs années,
avec les élèves de Prépa HEC
de toute la France ;
et que dans nos échanges,
je les tutoie,
eh bien je vais passer au tutoiement
dans cette vidéo.
Je m’adresse donc à toi,
cher préparationnaire :
je me présente,
parce que tu ne me connais peut-être pas
:
je suis Romain,
le créateur du site 1000 idées de culture
générale,
et auteur du manuel éponyme.
Je connais très bien la Prépa HEC,
parce que je suis moi-même passé par là
;
parce que je donne des cours des culture générale
à des élèves de Prépa HEC
depuis une dizaine d’années ;
et enfin parce que j’ai édité plusieurs
manuels
à destination des élèves de Prépa HEC.
Dernière petite précision me concernant
:
je travaille toujours en tandem
avec Haristote,
que voici ;
et c’est Haristote avec un H
parce qu’il est né en deux-mille onze.
Allez, trêve de précisions :
dans cette vidéo,
je vais commenter dans le détail
une dissertation de culture générale
qui a été notée dix-sept sur vingt
au concours d’entrée de HEC
de deux mille dix-sept.
Tu peux télécharger la copie de concours
avec ma correction
(une dissertation entièrement rédigée
sur le même sujet)
soit en cliquant sur le lien
qui apparaît en haut à droite de la vidéo,
soit sur celui qui est dans la description.
Après,
tu as juste à m’indiquer
ta filière
et ton adresse e-mail
pour recevoir la copie.
Alors,
cette copie de concours,
ce n’est pas n’importe laquelle ;
c’est celle de Fanny,
étudiante en deuxième année à HEC
à l’heure où je tourne cette vidéo.
C’est Fanny qui m’a contacté par Facebook,
il y a un peu plus d’un an,
pour me dire qu’elle avait réussi l’épreuve
de dissertation de culture générale
grâce à ma méthode dite « des paragraphes
»
- celle de mes petits manuels
50 paragraphes tout cuits.
Alors,
Fanny n’en avait qu’un,
elle,
de manuel,
mais désormais,
il y a le vert
- c’est la version références classiques
-
et puis le rouge,
la version références originales.
Donc Fanny a a réussi l’épreuve
avec dix-sept sur vingt,
OR,
comme elle le dit
dans son témoignage,
pour elle,
ça n’était pas une mince affaire,
la dissertation de culture générale :
elle l’avoue clairement,
son but c’était seulement
« d’éviter le pire en philo ».
Elle m’a plus précisément écrit :
« Je n'ai jamais été très bonne en philo,
je n'aimais pas travailler cette matière
en prépa.
Alors que je voulais seulement au début
« éviter le pire en philo »,
j'ai finalement eu des bonnes notes
(quatorze à l'EM Lyon et à l’ESSEC,
dix-sept à HEC)
essentiellement grâce à
la méthode des paragraphes tout cuits. »
La méthode des paragraphes tout cuits,
c’est donc celle de mon manuel
50 paragraphes tout cuits.
Et ce qu’il y a de très intéressant
dans la copie de concours de Fanny,
c’est qu’elle a,
d’un côté,
appliqué très rigoureusement
ma méthode des paragraphes ;
mais de l’autre,
elle s’est servi
des paragraphes précis du manuel
avec beaucoup de liberté.
En fait,
si je généralise,
il y a grosso modo
trois catégories d’élèves :
ceux,
tout d’abord,
qui apprennent les paragraphes du manuel par
coeur
et les recrachent le jour J
- ça peut donner de bons résultats,
mais ce n’est vraiment pas
ce que je recommande -
deuxième catégorie,
ensuite,
il y a les élèves qui apprennent les paragraphes
du manuel,
mais qui font un vrai effort,
le jour J,
pour adapter chaque paragraphe au sujet
- c’est,
de mon point de vue,
la meilleure manière de faire,
celle aussi qui conviendra
au plus grand nombre d’élèves de Prépa
HEC -
enfin,
troisième catégorie :
certains élèves,
comme Fanny,
attachent plus d’importance au format précis
des paragraphes du manuel,
et à la manière de les utiliser,
c’est-à-dire à la méthode des paragraphes
- ils connaissent les paragraphes,
mais pas par coeur,
et ils les utilisent très librement
tout en appliquant très rigoureusement
la méthode des paragraphes.
Donc si tu as peur d’avoir les mêmes paragraphes
que d’autres candidats
le jour J
- ce qui est évidemment,
soit dit en passant,
un fantasme paranoïaque,
parce qu’il y a trop de paragraphes
et que trop peu d’élèves
utilisent les manuels
et la méthode des paragraphes -
bref,
si tu n’arrives pas à te débarrasser
de cette peur infondée,
eh bien tu peux utiliser
les paragraphes du manuel
et la méthode des paragraphes
comme l’a fait Fanny.
Mais je vais t’expliquer plus en détail
ce que ça veut dire
dans la suite de la vidéo,
en commentant la copie.
Je te rappelle
que tu peux la télécharger
soit en cliquant sur le lien
qui apparaît en haut à droite de la vidéo,
soit sur celui qui est dans la description.
Je vais concentrer mon commentaire
sur quatre points :
tout d’abord,
l’efficacité globale de la méthodologie
de Fanny ;
ensuite,
l’efficacité de son usage de ma méthode
des paragraphes ;
l’efficacité,
également,
de son expression écrite ;
et puis
je soulignerai bien sûr
les erreurs
qui auraient pu lui coûter des points.
Je comparerai aussi,
à certains moments,
la copie de Fanny avec ma propre correction.
En revanche,
je ne parlerai pas du fond,
c’est-à-dire du thème de l’année deux-mille
dix-sept,
– qui était « la mémoire » –
parce que c’est sans intérêt pour toi.
En termes de méthode,
enfin,
je vais essayer de me mettre
à la place du correcteur :
de découvrir
et de lire la copie comme lui
- même si moi,
je te préviens,
je vais prendre davantage de temps,
aller plus
dans le détail,
et puis je crois aussi
que je suis plus exigeant.
Voici le sommaire de la vidéo :
je vais d’abord analyser
la première impression générale
que produit la copie ;
et puis je vais commenter ses parties
dans l’ordre suivant ;
introduction ;
conclusion ;
grand un ;
grand deux ;
et enfin,
grand trois.
Je conclurai chacune de ces parties de mon
commentaire
avec une synthèse des principaux points positifs
– ce dont tu dois t'inspirer –
et des principaux points négatifs
– ce que tu dois éviter.
Et puis bien sûr,
je ferai une conclusion finale,
dans laquelle je te dirai
si Fanny méritait vraiment dix-sept.
Si jamais tu veux aller directement
à une partie précise de la vidéo,
tu as juste à regarder dans le minutage de
la vidéo
qui est disponible dans la description.
Enfin,
tu peux me poser toutes tes questions dans
les commentaires,
et je m’engage à répondre à chacune d’entre
elles.
Allez,
maintenant il faut mettre les mains dans le
cambouis.
Je te précise que le thème de culture générale
de deux-mille dix-sept était la parole,
et que le sujet tombé à HEC était :
« Faire parler un texte. »
- ouais,
il était plutôt difficile,
voire très difficile.
Mais Fanny,
qui avait seulement pour ambition
« d’éviter le pire en philo »,
s’en est très bien sortie
grâce à ma méthode des paragraphes.
Voyons voir la première impression générale
que produit sa copie.
Allez,
une petite récompense
pour donner du courage à Haristote,
parce qu’il y a du travail.
Et c’est parti !
Voici donc la dissertation de concours que
tu as pu télécharger.
Le correcteur commence généralement par
jauger, en quelques secondes, l’état général
de la copie.
Ah mais ça me fait penser, il faut que je
te parle d’un truc.
Est-ce que tu sais ce qu’est
le biais de confirmation ?
C’est un effet psychologique
qui se produit dans de nombreux domaines,
et qui est très puissant.
Par exemple,
si tu rencontres une nouvelle personne,
tu en as une première impression :
dès les premières secondes,
tu remarques,
consciemment ou inconsciemment,
plein de choses,
qui sont connotées
positivement
ou négativement à tes yeux.
Eh bien,
cette première impression est fugace,
mais d’une importance cruciale,
car elle crée un biais :
si cette nouvelle personne produit sur toi
une bonne toute première impression,
tu vas avoir tendance à vouloir systématiquement
confirmer
cette première impression
en interprétant positivement
ce qu’elle dit
et fait par la suite ;
et inversement,
si la toute première impression est mauvaise.
Tu vois où je veux en venir ?
Comme le correcteur est un être humain,
une dissertation produit,
elle aussi,
un biais de confirmation.
Une copie qui fournit les signes
de la conformité aux attentes du correcteur
l’entraînera
– a priori inconsciemment –
à vouloir confirmer
cette première impression favorable,
c’est-à-dire à « surnoter » la dissertation
;
inversement,
une copie d’un abord désagréable
risque d’être « sous-notée ».
Tu as donc tout intérêt à faire en sorte
que ta dissertation produise
une bonne première impression
sur le correcteur.
On va voir plus précisément comment faire
en regardant la copie de Fanny.
C’est parti pour de bon,
Haristote !
Alors, quelle première impression la dissertation
de Fanny fournit-elle ?
Bon, au niveau de la calligraphie, ça va
: elle est plutôt lisible pour une copie
de concours, ni trop petite ni trop grosse.
On remarque immédiatement, dès l’introduction,
les alinéas bien marqués, ce qui facilite
évidemment la lecture – c’est donc un
premier bon point.
Comme le correcteur lit des centaines de copies
dans un court laps de temps, tout ce qui lui
rend la tâche moins pénible est susceptible
d’accroître sa tolérance.
Ensuite, les références sont bien soulignées
– mais bon, ça tous les candidats le font,
il n’y a, en général, pas de problème.
Je descends à la page 2.
On voit que les grandes parties (introduction,
grand I, grand II, grand III, et conclusion)
sont bien espacées ; et que Fanny a même
pris l’initiative de sauter une ligne entre
ces paragraphes – c’est un choix judicieux,
parce que ses paragraphes sont assez longs.
Je continue de descendre.
Alors, comme moi je suis assez tatillon, je
remarque, à la page 3, que Fanny utilise
des guillemets anglais ("") au lieu de guillemets
français (« ») : ce n’est pas très grave,
mais c’est à éviter.
Tu te souviendras : ça ce sont des guillemets
français, ceux que tu dois utiliser en dissertation
de culture générale ; et ceux-ci, ce sont
des guillemets anglais, à réserver… pour
l’anglais, qui est ta LV1 ou LV2 si je ne
m’abuse.
Je continue.
Je remarque une conclusion partielle à la
fin de chaque grande partie, ce qui est une
caractéristique supplémentaire d’une copie
sérieuse.
Je remarque aussi, comme c’est le cas dans
la plupart des copies, que les paragraphes
se font un peu moins longs au fur et à mesure
qu’on avance - mais bon, en regardant rapidement,
leur taille me semble toutefois rester dans
une proportion tolérable par rapport à celle
des premiers de la dissertation.
Je continue encore de descendre, et on arrive
à la conclusion.
Je suis agréablement surpris par sa longueur,
qui me donne l’impression favorable d’un
travail achevé - Fanny ne s’est pas contentée
de 3-4 lignes.
Je checke le nombre de pages : 10 pages, c'est
peut-être un tout petit peu au-dessus de
la moyenne sans être excessif – ça aussi,
c’est un plutôt un bon signe.
Alors,
que conclure de cette première impression
?
Honnêtement, il n’y a pas photo :
la dissertation de Fanny produit
une première impression positive,
voire très positive.
Du coup,
biais de confirmation oblige,
sa note a de bonnes chances
d’être tirée vers le haut.
Voici plus précisément
les trois atouts de la copie de Fanny
dont tu peux t’inspirer
pour produire une bonne première impression
(je te donne les atouts
par ordre d’importance décroissante) :
atout numéro un,
le marquage des alinéas ;
atout numéro deux,
l’aération de la copie ;
atout numéro trois,
le relatif équilibre des grandes parties
- je dis « relatif »
parce qu’il n’est pas parfait.
Comme la dissertation de Fanny
possède ces trois atouts,
on est enclin à penser,
dès les premières secondes de correction,
qu’il s’agit d’une bonne,
voire d’une très bonne copie.
Et encore une fois :
ça crée un biais de confirmation positif,
en vertu duquel
le correcteur aura tendance
à remarquer en priorité les choses réussies
dans la suite de la copie.
Allez,
je passe maintenant,
comme le correcteur,
à la lecture détaillée de l’introduction.
Je te rappelle que tu peux
me poser toutes tes questions
dans les commentaires.
Allez,
c’est parti pour l’intro !
Alors, je regarde un peu la tête de l’introduction.
Hé mais ça ressemble beaucoup à ma méthodologie,
ça !
Petite précision supplémentaire :
en fait,
comme Fanny avait travaillé
avec certaines de mes dissertations
- parce que chaque année,
j’en donne gratuitement plusieurs
aux élèves inscrits à ma newsletter -
donc comme Fanny les avait lues,
elle a appliqué ma méthodologie de l’introduction
:
un paragraphe par enjeu,
marqué par un alinéa.
C'est particulièrement pratique
à lire et à corriger.
Ce que je vais faire,
c’est commenter l’introduction de Fanny
paragraphe par paragraphe,
comme ça je vais aussi
te donner des conseils de méthodologie
pour l’introduction de la dissertation.
Allez,
on retourne dans la copie !
Comme dans ma méthodologie, le premier paragraphe
est intelligemment consacré à l’accroche
- et uniquement à l’accroche.
Fanny évoque un documentaire de 2016, À
voix haute, qui raconte la préparation d’un
concours d’éloquence par de jeunes étudiants
de quartiers.
Donc là, il s’agit bien sûr d’une référence
originale.
Pour rappel (comme les étudiants de Prépa
HEC me posent souvent la question), il existe,
selon moi, 5 types d’accroche possibles
(je te les donne par ordre de difficulté,
et de risque, croissant) :
tu peux commencer ta copie par une référence
(par exemple : « Descartes avance dans le
Discours de la méthode que… ») ;
tu peux utiliser plus précisément une citation
(par exemple, « Quand tu prends confiance
en la confiance tu deviens confiant. » Jean-Claude
Van Damme) ;
tu peux raconter une anecdote (par exemple
« Les disciples d’Épicure se réunissaient
dans l’école dite "du Jardin", où etc…
») ;
plus difficile, tu peux faire référence
à un fait d’actualité ou récent (par
exemple « Une équipe de chercheurs du laboratoire
de neurobiologie de l’université américaine
de Stanford a montré en septembre 2018 que…
») ;
enfin, tu peux partir d'une statistique (par
exemple : « Selon une étude de 2017 du cabinet
Deloitte, 1 Français sur 9 était abonné
à une salle de fitness en 2016. »).
Fanny, elle, comme tu le vois, elle a opté
pour la première solution.
Et sa référence est originale à deux titres
: il s’agit d’un documentaire, et ce documentaire
est récent. Alors ça pouvait être risqué,
mais le risque est largement couvert par la
pertinence de l’accroche sur le fond,
et puis aussi par le soin apporté à le démontrer
sur la forme.
De manière générale, une référence récente
demande un effort supplémentaire sur le plan
de l’expression écrite, parce que la rigueur
et le classicisme du style contribuent à
faire tolérer l’originalité, entre guillemets,
de la référence – une référence récente
introduite avec des défauts de style produirait
une dangereuse impression de vulgarité, c’est
ça le risque.
Fanny, elle, a coché toutes les cases pour
que le correcteur adhère à son choix.
Son paragraphe d’accroche :
- développe un peu la référence (dans les
2 premières phrases) ;
- justifie la pertinence de la référence
par rapport au sujet (c’est la fonction
de la 3ème phrase) ;
- et puis, enfin, le paragraphe d'accroche
est rédigé très efficacement : il est très
clair et ne comporte aucune faute d’expression.
En dernière instance, ma seule réticence
est que la dernière phrase de l’accroche
– que j’appelle dans ma méthodologie
« la justification du sujet » – ma réticence
est que cette phrase soit une question, parce
que ça peut entraîner une confusion entre
l’enjeu de l’accroche, d’une part - qui
est simplement de faire rentrer le correcteur
dans la dissertation en créant un biais de
confirmation positif -
et l'enjeu de la problématisation, d’autre
part.
Il ne faut donc pas confondre les enjeux de
l’accroche et de la problématisation, comme
l’a un peu fait Fanny.
En effet, plus les enjeux de l’introduction
sont clairement et précisément délimités,
plus la lecture du correcteur sera facile
(ou moins pénible).
Moi, pour conclure le paragraphe d’accroche
de Fanny, j’aurais plutôt écrit quelque
chose comme : « Cet exemple nous invite à
réfléchir plus profondément à l’influence
de la parole orale sur la parole écrite ».
Allez, je passe maintenant au deuxième paragraphe
de l’introduction.
Bon, Fanny reste fidèle à ma méthodologie
de l'introduction : elle consacre ce deuxième
paragraphe à la définition des termes du
sujet.
Je constate aussi qu’elle s’inspire du
format de mes paragraphes « tout cuits » en
commençant avec une phrase aussi claire que
courte (avec un seul verbe conjugué, notamment)
: « L’expression "faire parler un texte"
revêt différentes significations ».
Avec cette phrase, elle indique au correcteur
de manière très transparente qu’elle s’apprête
à énoncer les divers sens possibles de l’expression.
Aucune prise de tête : Fanny sait exactement
ce qu’elle fait, et le correcteur le sait
lui aussi - tout est très clair.
Et ça, énormément d’élèves de Prépa
HEC me le disent : le style très clair des
paragraphes du manuel les a fait beaucoup
progresser en expression écrite.
En pratique, beaucoup reprennent exactement
le même format de paragraphe, non seulement
en dissertation de culture générale, mais
aussi en histoire ou en économie, en contraction
et en synthèse, en langues, etc.
C’est ce que j'explique dans la préface
du manuel 50 paragraphes tout cuits : ce manuel
ne sert pas seulement à être plus efficace
dans le développement de la dissertation
en le préparant à l'avance ; il donne plus
généralement une véritable méthode, une
méthode à la portée de tout élève de
Prépa HEC, pour écrire clairement.
Et puis, ce dont les candidats ne se rendent
généralement pas encore compte, c’est
qu’écrire clairement, c’est une compétence
profonde qui sera ensuite cruciale au cours
de leur vie professionnelle.
Bref, j’ai un peu digressé là, mais ce
que je veux te dire, c’est que ma méthode
des paragraphes sert aussi à écrire plus
clairement.
Je reviens à la définition des termes dans
la copie de Fanny.
Après la première phrase, elle précise
ensuite, sur le fond, que les divers sens
de l'expression sont déterminés par le rôle
de l’acteur (celui qui « fait parler »), ou
par l’effet produit par la parole (« donner
vie » au texte, le rendre « parlant »).
Alors, sur la forme, ce paragraphe de définition
des termes est très efficace : l’expression
est très claire ; on distingue facilement
les idées ; et les phrases s’enchaînent
avec fluidité grâce au lien logique présent
dans chacune d'elles.
Tu vois… « en effet »… il y a aussi
« tantôt… tantôt… »… « pas seulement
»… « également »… bon il y en a tellement
que ça devient chiant.
Il y a encore « aussi »… « ainsi »… et
« alors »…
Bref, on est servi - Fanny ne lésine pas
de ce côté-là.
Donc, sur la forme, elle assure.
Sur le plan du fond et de la méthodo, en
revanche, c’est moins bien.
Ce que fait Fanny dans ce paragraphe, c'est
tout d’abord définir l’expression complète,
alors qu’il faut la découper ; puis elle
confond l’enjeu de la définition des termes
avec celui de la problématisation.
Or, il suffisait, en gros, de définir l’expression
« faire parler » ; et puis le nom commun
« texte ».
Voici la définition des termes que j’ai
proposée dans ma correction.
Je te la montre quelques secondes, et je te
laisse mettre la vidéo en pause si tu veux
la lire.
En dérivant trop rapidement, elle, vers une
problématisation complexe, Fanny finit par
commettre une déficience logique :
« Ainsi, cela revient à jouer sur les sons
et le sens des mots. »
Non, « faire en sorte qu’un texte devienne
parlant pour le lecteur ou l’auditeur », ça
ne revient pas à « à jouer sur les sons
et le sens des mots » !
Mais bon, je ne suis pas censé parler du
fond, et le correcteur n’a pas le temps,
ou l’envie de remarquer ce type d’erreur.
Tu peux juste retenir que dévier de la méthodologie
t’entraînera à commettre des erreurs sur
le fond.
Fanny pose ensuite différentes questions
: alors, elles sont introduites et formulées
clairement, mais elles paraissent quand même
parachutées.
Donc, sur le fond, la définition des termes
de Fanny n’est pas terrible - après, le
sujet était vraiment difficile.
Allez, je passe au paragraphe suivant, dédié,
normalement, à la problématisation.
Je crois
qu'un petit rappel de méthodologie s’impose.
Qu’est-ce que la problématisation ?
C’est la partie de l’introduction
de ta dissertation
qui consiste à DIVISER
le problème de l’énoncé
en sous-problèmes.
La PROBLÉMATIQUE,
c'est la QUESTION
qui énonce
le problème général posé par le sujet,
et auquel tu dois proposer des éléments
de réponse
dans ta dissertation.
En pratique,
je te conseille d’entamer
le paragraphe de l’introduction
consacré à la problématisation,
le troisième paragraphe,
par ce que je nomme,
dans ma méthodologie de la dissertation,
le « point de départ de la réflexion ».
Alors,
qu’est-ce que le « point de départ de
la réflexion » ?
C'est l’aspect
le plus évidemment FRAPPANT
du sujet.
Cet aspect doit être une idée
à la dois évidente
et simple.
Pour le sujet de cette dissertation
– « Faire parler un texte » –
par exemple,
le meilleur point de départ de la réflexion
était,
de mon point de vue,
l’apparente impossibilité de conférer
à un texte
la faculté de la parole orale
– c’est-à-dire que la correspondance
entre la métaphore de l’énoncé,
« faire parler un texte », d’une part,
et la réalité et ses phénomènes,
d’autre part,
cette correspondance semble de prime abord
problématique,
sinon impossible.
Dit plus simplement :
au sens propre,
« faire parler un texte »,
c'est une hypothèse délirante.
Cette idée évidente
et simple
prise pour point de départ,
ou tremplin de la réflexion,
j’ai pris l’habitude,
dans mes dissertations,
de la développer en quelques phrases
(minimum deux)
au début du troisième paragraphe
de l’introduction de la dissertation.
Voici ce que ça donne dans ma correction
- comme il y a une minute, mets la vidéo
en pause si tu veux lire le passage.
Alors,
ce passage est exceptionnellement long
dans mon introduction,
mais c'est parce que j’ai voulu
clarifier le problème au maximum
en raison de la difficulté du sujet.
Les différentes questions de la problématisation
(idéalement trois)
qui expriment les sous-problèmes
du problème principal,
ces questions ne viennent
que dans un second temps,
puisqu’elles découlent du point de départ
de la réflexion.
Bon,
j’espère que c’est un peu plus clair
pour toi
avec ce petit point méthodo
sur le paragraphe consacré à la problématisation
dans l’introduction de la dissertation.
Je retourne à la copie de Fanny.
Fanny, elle, consacre ce troisième paragraphe
de son introduction à une problématique
trop longue et trop compliquée – d’ailleurs,
c’est peut-être le plus gros défaut de
sa copie.
« En quoi la capacité à faire parler un
texte, si elle revêt certes des aspects positifs,
implique-t-elle des dangers, créant notamment
un rapport fiduciaire - c’est-à-dire un
rapport fondé sur la confiance - entre les
hommes et entre les types de paroles ? »
Honnêtement, c’est prise de tête.
Bon, Fanny a néanmoins réussi à « faire
passer la pilule » grâce à l’efficacité
de son style, et puis aussi, plus précisément,
grâce à l’illusion de cohérence produite
par les liens logiques – par exemple la
phrase de ce paragraphe commence par l’adverbe
« dès lors » alors même qu’elle ne constitue
pas une conséquence de ce qui précède.
Donc là, elle escroque un peu le correcteur.
Allez, je passe au dernier paragraphe de son
introduction, l’annonce de plan.
Dans mes dissertations, je saute généralement
une ligne entre la problématique et l’annonce
de plan – mais c’est un détail qui n’influence
en rien le correcteur, tant que les choses
sont claires pour lui.
De même, les variantes de formulation de
l’annonce de plan, ou encore la question
de savoir s’il faut préciser le numéro
de la partie entre parenthèses, ça ce sont
des choses avec lesquelles tu ne dois pas
te prendre la tête - ce sont des broutilles
qui ne méritent pas ton attention.
Souviens-toi qu’on donne souvent son attention
à l’accessoire au détriment de l’essentiel.
Alors, le plan de Fanny.
« Dans un premier temps, voyons qu’il existe
différentes manières de faire parler un
texte, de le rendre vivant.
Expliquons alors les raisons pour lesquelles
un écrivain, un orateur ou un auditeur souhaite
faire parler un texte.
Montrons finalement que cette capacité à
faire parler un texte admet des limites, provoquant
des dangers pour les hommes et pour la parole-même.
»
C’est très clair, mais elle aurait pu éviter
la répétition de l’expression du sujet,
« faire parler un texte » - ou alors ne
la répéter que dans la troisième phrase.
Dans cette 3ème phrase d’ailleurs, « provoquer
des dangers » n’est pas très élégant
- je préfère par exemple « créer des risques
», mais c’est un détail.
Non, le gros défaut de son plan, c'est qu’il
ne répond pas rigoureusement à la question
de la problématique, qui porte, si je la
simplifie, sur les potentiels « dangers » liés
à la capacité de « faire parler un texte
».
Pourtant, le principe de méthodologie à
appliquer est simple : la problématique exprime,
sous la forme d’une question, le problème
général du sujet ; et le plan du développement
de la dissertation constitue une réponse,
dialectique et progressive (en plusieurs parties),
à cette question.
Dans ma méthodologie, la qualité du plan
se vérifie en effectuant ce que j’appelle
un « test de pertinence » : tu lis simplement
à la suite la problématique et l’annonce
de plan pour savoir dans quelle mesure le
plan constitue bien une réponse pertinente
à la problématique.
Si tu touches la cible, c’est que ton plan
est bon.
Dans le plan de Fanny, le I et le II sont
à l’évidence hors-sujet par rapport à
la question « En quoi la capacité à faire
parler un texte […] implique-t-elle des
dangers ? ».
En fait, c’est quasi uniquement son III
qui répond à sa problématique.
Faisons maintenant le test avec la problématique
et le plan de ma correction :
« L’usage d’un texte pourrait-il vraiment
recourir à une forme de parole (orale) issue
de la parole écrite elle-même ?
Si la parole au sens strict semble de prime
abord impropre à décrire l’usage d’un
texte (I), il apparaît cependant qu’elle
possède un rôle fondateur à l’égard
de la parole écrite (II), c’est pourquoi
elle rend tout de même possibles des usages
de la parole écrite qui révèlent une forme
d’oralité au sein même du texte (III).
»
Tu vois, là ça colle.
Je pense que le plan aspects-causes-limites
de Fanny passe tout de même parce qu’il
est malgré tout très clair - l’efficacité
de la forme compense les déficiences de fond.
Alors,
petite conclusion
sur l’introduction de Fanny.
Tu l’as compris,
elle est loin d’être parfaite.
Voici les trois points positifs
que tu peux en retenir
(je te les présente
par ordre d’importance décroissante) :
premier point,
son style est d’une clarté idéale
pour les concours ;
deuxième point,
la division en quatre paragraphes,
comme dans mes dissertations,
facilite la lecture du correcteur ;
et troisième point,
l’accroche réussie
crée un biais de confirmation
positif.
Maintenant,
il y a aussi des défauts
que tu ne dois pas reproduire
(je te les présente
toujours par ordre d’importance
décroissante) :
tout d’abord,
le mélange des enjeux
(en l’occurence,
la définition des termes
et la problématisation)
- ce qu’il faut,
je te l’ai déjà dit,
c’est que tu consacres
un seul et unique enjeu
à chaque paragraphe de l’introduction :
accroche,
définition des termes,
problématisation,
et annonce de plan ;
deuxième défaut de l’intro de Fanny :
la complexité de la problématique ;
et troisième défaut principal :
la déconnexion de la problématique
et du plan
- on a fait le test de pertinence,
on a lu la problématique
et le plan à la suite,
et ça ne marche pas.
Donc,
encore une fois,
l’introduction de Fanny est loin d’être
parfaite ;
pour autant,
l’impression globale qui en émane est positive
– voire très positive
selon les copies corrigées juste avant –
et ça pour deux raisons :
la première,
c’est que le sujet était difficile ;
et la seconde raison,
c’est que,
comme je le dis souvent,
la clarté de l’expression écrite
est survalorisée aux concours.
Du coup,
si je me mets à la place du correcteur,
je trouve qu’à ce stade,
la copie de Fanny est bien partie
pour être notée
entre quatorze
et vingt.
L’impression globale que j’en ai
est pour l'instant positive,
voire très positive.
Je vais maintenant commenter la conclusion
:
elle est souvent lue
en tandem avec l’introduction,
parce que ça permet d’évaluer
la cohérence globale de la dissertation.
Si tu as des questions,
je te rappelle que ça se passe
dans les commentaires.
Alors,
je te rappelle que
la finalité conventionnelle de la conclusion
est simplement de « boucler la boucle »
en rappelant les résultats de la réflexion.
Cette partie n’est donc pas un enjeu de
fond,
mais uniquement de forme.
De mon point de vue,
la manière la plus simple de s’y prendre
est de rédiger une sorte de mini contraction
du développement.
Dans mes conclusions,
je résume généralement
chaque grande partie du développement
en deux phrases
– la première pour évoquer l’idée générale,
la seconde pour synthétiser
les trois arguments.
Maintenant,
qu’en est-il de la conclusion de Fanny ?
Sa conclusion n’est pas bâclée – comme
c’est le cas dans de nombreuses copies – et
elle présente les qualités attendues : elle
synthétise le propos du développement avec
la même efficacité de style que celle de
l’introduction ; et puis elle ne cherche
pas à faire lever le correcteur de sa chaise
avec des réflexions transcendantes.
Tu peux remarquer que même dans cette toute
dernière partie d’une importance marginale
sur le fond, alors même qu’elle est probablement
pressée par le temps, Fanny apporte un soin
particulier à la cohérence du paragraphe
en liant systématiquement toutes les phrases
entre elles.
Les phrases 2, 3 et 4 développent et précisent
l’idée générale de la toute première
- c’est encore une fois le format de mes
paragraphes « tout cuits » - puis on trouve
dans les phrases 5, 6 et 7 des liens respectivement
d’opposition - « Néanmoins » - d’addition
- « Plus encore » - et de conséquence - « donc
».
De manière générale, contrairement à ce
que croient beaucoup d’élèves en Prépa
HEC, c’est ce soin particulier qui fait
sortir la copie du lot, et non pas une référence
originale que le correcteur ne remarquera
probablement même pas, ou bien qui ne sera
pas originale pour lui, qui lit du Montaigne
au petit déjeuner.
Pour conclure,
comme l’écrit Fanny,
les trois atouts de sa conclusion
dont tu peux t’inspirer,
ce sont :
numéro un,
sa consistance
- parce qu’elle ne se réduit pas
à trois lignes ;
numéro deux,
la clarté de l’expression ;
et numéro trois,
l’efficacité de la synthèse du développement.
En clair,
je trouve que la conclusion de Fanny
est quasiment parfaite.
Son seul défaut,
c’est d’être un peu moins rigoureusement
scolaire
– et ça,
être rigoureusement scolaire
c’est une qualité
dans la perspective des concours –
donc je la trouve un peu moins scolaire
à la fin du paragraphe,
en particulier parce qu'elle termine
avec une image journalistique
(« un jeu à double tranchant »)
qui est inadaptée.
Mais bon,
ce détail mis à part,
Fanny a rédigé
une très bonne conclusion.
Allez,
je passe au développement de la dissertation.
Comme tu le sais probablement déjà,
le correcteur le lit plus rapidement,
souvent en diagonale.
Ce n’est donc pas
ce qu’il y a de plus important dans la copie
- c’est l’introduction,
qui sert un peu d'échantillon représentatif
de toute la dissertation,
qui est la partie la plus importante.
Mais bon,
le développement n’est pas à négliger
pour autant.
Allez,
on retourne dans la copie de Fanny !
Alors, la première petite chose que je remarque
est que Fanny n’a pas fait d’introduction
partielle pour son grand I. Par « introduction
partielle », j’entends 2-3 phrases qui
rappellent l’idée générale de la grande
partie.
Voici par exemple celle de ma correction :
« La pertinence de l’expression « faire
parler un texte » apparaît de prime abord
problématique dans la mesure où elle néglige
l’apparente hétérogénéité de la parole
orale et de la parole écrite. Or, cette hétérogénéité
semble insurmontable pour plusieurs raisons.
»
Que Fanny s’en soit passée n’est pas
grave du tout - les bonnes, ou très bonnes
copies sont pleines d’imperfections (quand
les mauvaises sont pleines de détails réussis).
Je regarde le premier paragraphe du grand
I.
Il ne s’agit pas d’un paragraphe du manuel
50 paragraphes tout cuits, je te le dis tout
de suite - c’est en fait un paragraphe préparé
par Fanny elle-même sur le modèle de ceux
du manuel.
Comme je le recommande dans ma méthode des
paragraphes, la première phrase est extrêmement
claire, même si elle aurait pu être plus
courte – en mettant le point après le mot
« formes ».
La locution adverbiale « Tout d’abord » indique
bien au correcteur qu’elle va présenter
ses idées de manière ordonnée.
La suite du paragraphe est aussi limpide,
très bien structurée (« Tout d’abord…
Premièrement… également… »), et les
liens logiques produisent une bonne impression
de cohérence.
La référence n’est introduite qu’à
la quatrième phrase, ce qui montre que Fanny
a compris que la dissertation est un exercice
d’argumentation ; et que dans cet exercice,
les références ne servent qu’à donner
plus de force aux arguments.
Enfin, comme dans les paragraphes de mon manuel,
la dernière phrase rappelle de manière plus
précise l’idée de la première, c’est-à-dire
l’argument.
L’expression « faire parler un texte » revient
à quatre reprises, ce qui témoigne de l’obsession
qu'a Fanny de traiter très précisément
le sujet, et uniquement le sujet.
Le seul défaut du paragraphe est la présence
de deux références (Verlaine et Francis
Ponge, qui sont des références classiques),
à quoi s’ajoute le fait que la seconde
est évoquée en une seule phrase.
De mon point de vue,
deux références dans un même paragraphe,
c’est vraiment un mauvais choix.
Beaucoup d’élèves me disent qu’ils le
font
pour donner davantage de références au correcteur,
mais je te le redis :
les références ne sont pas
ce qu’il y a de plus important en dissertation
;
et puis surtout,
les supposés avantages d’un couple de références
ne compensent pas les inconvénients.
Il y en a trois principaux :
déjà,
c’est un facteur de complexité :
c’est assez difficile comme ça
de mobiliser une seule référence,
et puis il peut être très difficile
de relier les 2 références.
Deuxième inconvénient principal :
deux références dans le même paragraphe,
ça risque produire de la confusion chez le
correcteur,
alors que,
je te le redis,
ton but,
c’est de lui rendre la vie facile ;
Enfin,
troisième et dernier inconvénient :
ça peut être pris pour du name dropping
- et d’ailleurs,
tu verras qu’il y en a
dans la copie de Fanny.
En conclusion,
je te recommande donc
de concentrer chaque paragraphe
sur UNE SEULE
ET UNIQUE référence,
qui soit la plus pertinente possible
par rapport à l’argument.
Là,
Fanny a un peu dévié
de ma méthode des paragraphes,
mais au global,
le premier paragraphe de son développement
est très efficace.
Je passe au paragraphe suivant.
Ce deuxième paragraphe est très similaire
au premier. C’est encore un paragraphe que
Fanny a préparé elle-même en s’inspirant
de ceux de mon manuel, puis adapté au sujet.
Alors, il est introduit très simplement par
l’adverbe « ensuite » – qui a tout de
même le mérite de présenter explicitement
un ordre ; il commence lui aussi par une phrase
très claire, et cette fois-ci courte, qui
expose l’argument : « Ensuite, l’orateur,
quand il déclame un texte, peut également
le faire parler, c’est-à-dire lui donner
vie. »
Le paragraphe est bien structuré et d’une
lecture fluide grâce aux liens logiques (« Ensuite
», « Pour ce faire », deux fois « alors
», « En effet », bon j’arrête parce
que ça ne finira jamais - grosso modo il
y a un lien logique par phrase) ;
la référence n'est présentée qu’à la
quatrième phrase ; l’expression « faire
parler un texte » revient 7 fois (7 fois
! là elle n’y va pas avec le dos de la
cuillère Fanny) ; et enfin la conclusion
partielle rappelle l’argument en le précisant
un peu.
Alors, on retrouve le même défaut que dans
le premier paragraphe : deux références
(qui sont également classiques).
Sinon, ce paragraphe est lui aussi globalement
très efficace.
Je passe au troisième paragraphe.
Toujours préparé par Fanny elle-même selon
ma méthode, ce dernier paragraphe est cependant
sensiblement plus court que les deux précédents.
Je dirais qu’il est plus court d’environ
40%.
Après, il est quasi similaire sur la forme
: conformément à ma méthode des paragraphes,
une première phrase très claire présente
l’argument : « Enfin, l’auditeur ou le
lecteur a également la capacité à faire
parler un texte, c’est-à-dire à donner
différentes interprétations au texte. »
Le paragraphe a toujours une structure explicite
; moult liens logiques ; l’introduction
de la référence est faite à la quatrième
phrase ; l’expression de l’énoncé, « faire
parler un texte », apparaît 3 fois ; et
enfin, on retrouve bien une mini conclusion
partielle : « Ici, le spectateur est libre
de faire parler le texte comme il l’entend
».
Ce 3ème et dernier paragraphe se distingue
des 2 premiers à 2 titres :
il comporte une seule et unique référence
– et en cela, je le trouve plus efficace
(même s’il est moins développé) ;
et puis la référence, un film de 2016, est
cette fois-ci originale.
D’un côté, comme il se concentre sur une
seule référence, ce paragraphe correspond
davantage à l’idéal de ma méthode ; mais
d’un autre côté, je lui trouve quand même
2 défauts :
le 1er défaut, c’est une grosse faute de
conjugaison à la 2ème phrase (« interpeller
» à l'infinitif au lieu du participe passé)
- et tu vois que le correcteur, qui est un
radar, l’a bien évidemment trouvée cette
faute ;
le 2nd défaut, c’est le choix de la référence
qui n’est pas judicieux : Juste la fin du
monde est un film qui date de 2016, donc très
récent, et qui est plutôt mal noté - en
plus, on termine seulement le grand I, et
Fanny a déjà cité 2 films, donc ça fait
trop.
Mais bon, en dernière instance, son 3ème
paragraphe est tout de même efficace, comme
les 2 premiers.
Fanny enchaîne avec la conclusion partielle
de son grand I : « Ainsi, tant l’écrivain
que l’orateur ou l’auditeur peuvent faire
parler un texte. Pourquoi cherchent-ils à
donner vie aux paroles écrites ou orales
? ».
Ce sont donc deux phrases courtes : la 1ère
pour rappeler l’idée générale de la partie
; la seconde, la question, pour faire la transition
vers l’idée générale du grand II.
C’est très simple et très efficace, je
n’ai rien à redire.
Alors,
que penser,
en conclusion,
de cette première grande partie ?
Sur la forme,
elle est de très bonne facture.
Les trois choses dont tu peux t’inspirer,
ce sont
(je te les donne toujours
par ordre d’importance décroissante) :
l’obsession de Fanny
à rester « dans » le sujet
- on le voit bien
avec la répétition systématique de l’expression
« faire parler un texte » ;
la deuxième chose,
c’est la clarté de l’expression écrite
;
et enfin la troisième,
c’est la structuration des paragraphes
- ceux de cette première grande partie,
Fanny les a préparés elle-même
sur le modèle de ceux
du manuel 50 paragraphes tout cuits,
puis elle les a adaptés à son argumentation.
Alors,
malgré ces trois atouts,
ce grand un n’est pas un modèle
pour une raison particulière :
je te l’ai déjà dit :
ce n’est pas une bonne idée
d’avoir plus d’une référence dans un
paragraphe
– si ce n’est de manière exceptionnelle,
par exemple lorsqu’un auteur répond à
un autre.
Allez,
je passe maintenant à la deuxième grande
partie.
Je te rappelle que si tu as des questions,
tu peux me les poser dans les commentaires.
Alors, Fanny commence ce grand II avec une
introduction partielle pour rappeler l’idée
générale de la partie : « Voyons maintenant
que le fait même de faire parler un texte
est entrepris pour différentes raisons ».
C’est une bonne chose, mais ça aurait été
mieux de la séparer du premier paragraphe
proprement dit avec un alinéa.
Ce paragraphe est le premier de la dissertation
qui est tiré du manuel 50 paragraphes tout
cuits. Il s’agissait plus précisément
du n°23 de l’édition sur le thème de
la parole - je ne vais pas te le lire entièrement,
je te le montre juste quelques secondes à
l’écran, comme ça tu pourras revenir dessus
en mettant la vidéo en pause si tu le souhaites.
Maintenant, comment Fanny l’a-t-elle utilisé
?
Elle a tout d’abord rédigé elle-même,
la première phrase, l’argument conformément
à ma méthode des paragraphes : « Tout d’abord,
pour l’écrivain, faire parler son texte
lui permet de mieux transmettre son message
».
C’est donc une phrase très claire qui reprend
en plus l’expression de l’énoncé, ce
qui permet à Fanny de montrer qu'elle a l’obsession
de traiter le sujet, et rien que le sujet.
Le paragraphe du manuel proprement dit ne
commence qu’à la troisième phrase : « Il
est souvent reproché à la parole… ».
Fanny l’utilise très librement :
- elle n’utilise, grosso modo, que la moitié
du paragraphe ;
- elle n’en reprend pas les phrases mot
pour mot, elle s’inspire simplement de la
formulation ;
- et surtout, elle les adapte très intelligemment
au sujet et à son argument - par exemple
quand elle écrit que Verlaine « fait parler
» ses poèmes.
Pour finir, elle ajoute une conclusion partielle
qui rappelle l’argument.
Si ce paragraphe est peut-être un peu court
par rapport à ceux du grand I, il est très
bon sur le plan de la méthode. Non seulement
Fanny a sélectionné un paragraphe du manuel
pertinent sur le fond, mais elle l’a surtout
adapté intelligemment au sujet et à son
argumentation. Elle se l’est vraiment appropriée
pour les besoins de l’épreuve.
Ça montre que tu n’es pas obligé, comme
le croient certains élèves de Prépa HEC,
d’apprendre par coeur les paragraphes des
2 manuels, puis de les recracher - je le dis
souvent, mais le titre du manuel, 50 paragraphes
TOUT CUITS, et puis l’image de la couverture,
c’est une provocation qui ne reflète pas
tous les usages possibles des paragraphes.
En réalité, comme Fanny, tu peux utiliser
les paragraphes du manuel très librement
en appliquant rigoureusement la méthode des
paragraphes.
Allez, fin de la digression. Je passe au paragraphe
suivant.
Le deuxième paragraphe de ce grand II est
lui issu du manuel 50 paragraphes tout cuits.
Comme depuis le début de la dissertation,
Fanny reproduit le format des paragraphes
du manuel : elle commence avec une phrase
très claire qui présente l’argument ; puis
elle développe l'argument avec une phrase
qui vise à préciser l’idée précédente.
Elle introduit ensuite un passage, seulement
2 phrases, du paragraphe n°43 du manuel (avec
la référence à Victor Klemperer) ; et après,
elle utilise, trois phrases plus loin, et
pour une seule phrase, le paragraphe n°24
(avec la référence à Danton).
Fanny fait donc encore, comme dans le paragraphe
précédent, un usage très libre des paragraphes
du manuel.
Cette fois-ci, cependant, je trouve qu’elle
prend un risque.
Le premier problème, c’est encore une fois
le doublement de la référence, dont je t’ai
déjà exposé les inconvénients. En l’occurrence,
en plus, j’aurais inversé l’ordre des
deux références en soulignant que la seconde
illustre le versant négatif de la première
(le risque de manipulation afférent à la
capacité à « faire parler un texte ») - mais
bon, je ne suis pas censé parler du fond.
Le second problème est que Fanny verse carrément
dans le name dropping : deux phrases seulement
consacrées à la première référence ! Et
une seule à la seconde ! C’est vraiment
trop peu. C’est du name dropping, et c’est
condamnable.
À quoi bon mobiliser une référence si c’est
pour l’évoquer en une phrase ? Non, tu
dois la développer au moins en 3-4 phrases
pour montrer en quoi elle étaye l’idée
du paragraphe, c’est-à-dire l’argument
présenté par la première phrase.
En conclusion, je ne te recommande pas, en
termes de méthode, de t’inspirer de ce
paragraphe du développement.
Cela étant dit, il présente toujours les
mêmes qualités de clarté, de cohérence
et de fluidité que les précédents - or,
ces qualités sont très valorisées aux concours.
Mais bon, c’est quand même le 1er paragraphe
un peu en-dessous.
Voyons voir ce qu’il en est du dernier du
grand II.
Ouh là ! Ce troisième paragraphe est excessivement
court (4 phrases), et il le paraît d’autant
plus que les deux premiers paragraphes du
développement étaient très longs.
De surcroît, je ne vois pas de référence,
alors même que la plupart des paragraphes
précédents en combinaient deux. C’est
le comble quand même : mobiliser 2 références
par paragraphe, et finir avec un paragraphe
riquiqui sans aucune référence !
L’expression est toujours très claire ; les
liens logiques sont bien présents ; mais
ce paragraphe constitue véritablement, jusqu’ici,
le point bas de la dissertation – là, la
qualité de l’expression est impuissante
à compenser la faiblesse de ce passage.
Avec un tel paragraphe, vraiment raté, Fanny
fait une croix sur les 18-19-20, des notes
qui n’étaient pas exclues à la lecture
de tout ce qui précède.
Bon, on voit ensuite la conclusion partielle
du grand II (qui paraît même longue comparée
au dernier paragraphe). Elle est rédigée
sur le même modèle que celle du grand I,
elle est simple et efficace.
Tu l’as compris :
cette deuxième grande partie est,
à l’évidence,
bien en dessous de la première.
Les trois erreurs
que tu ne dois pas reproduire,
ce sont
(je te les donne encore
par ordre d’importance décroissante) :
un,
faire un paragraphe « avorton »,
comme le troisième de ce grand deux,
qui se réduit à quelques phrases
et qui est dépourvu de référence :
deux,
faire du name dropping
comme dans le deuxième paragraphe
- et là c’est d’autant plus flagrant
que Fanny a encore combiné deux références
;
et enfin,
troisième erreur à éviter :
bah je viens de le dire,
combiner deux références
dans un même paragraphe.
Je pourrais aussi souligner
que les paragraphes paraissent finalement
courts
en comparaison
des deux premiers paragraphes
du développement de la dissertation.
En définitive,
ce grand deux n'est donc pas terrible.
Pour autant,
on retrouve tout de même
l’obsession de Fanny à rester « dans » le
sujet
et aussi la clarté de son expression écrite
- et encore une fois,
ce sont des qualités précieuses.
Allez,
je passe à la troisième
et dernière grande partie.
Je te rappelle que si tu as des questions,
tu peux me les poser dans la partie commentaires.
Comme au début de la deuxième grande partie,
Fanny écrit l’introduction partielle dans
le premier paragraphe – ce n’est pas très
grave, mais, je te l’ai déjà dit, c’est
plus clair de les séparer.
« Finalement, montrons que la possibilité
de faire parler un texte admet des limites,
voire peut se révéler dangereuse pour l’homme
ou pour la parole-même. »
Dans cette introduction partielle, l’emploi
du verbe « montrer » révèle bien, une
fois de plus, que Fanny a pris de la mesure
de l’exercice, car elle se place explicitement
dans un processus d’argumentation - elle
annonce au correcteur qu’elle s’apprête
à démontrer la pertinence de l’idée générale
de son grand III.
Fanny ne se prend pas non plus la tête pour
introduire cette troisième grande partie
: l’adverbe « finalement » n’a rien
de génial, mais il signale très simplement
et très clairement qu’on arrive à la dernière
phase de l’argumentation.
Alors, le premier paragraphe proprement dit,
il a été préparé par Fanny elle-même
sur le modèle de ceux du manuel ; puis elle
l’a adapté au sujet.
Il est d’une bonne longueur, et puis il
possède les mêmes qualités que les bons
paragraphes précédents : première phrase
relativement courte (un seul verbe conjugué)
et limpide : « Premièrement, en faisant
parler un texte, l’auditeur ou le lecteur
risque de trahir l’interprétation première
de l’écrivain ou de l’orateur ».
Une structure transparente, en commençant
avec l’adverbe « Premièrement » ; une
cohérence accrue grâce aux liens logiques
; cinq occurrences de l'expression « faire
parler un texte » pour montrer qu’on est
dans le sujet ; l’expression est toujours
très claire ; et enfin, la petite conclusion
partielle qui va bien.
Après, ce paragraphe présente cependant
deux défauts non négligeables :
le premier, c’est que la référence est
introduite juste après l’argument, ce qui
est trop tôt - je te rappelle qu’il faut
idéalement 2-3 phrases entre l’introduction
de l’argument et celle de la référence
-
et le second défaut, c’est qu'une seconde
référence (Pour un oui ou pour un non, de
Nathalie Sarraute, une pièce de théâtre
qui compte plutôt comme une référence noble)
- donc cette seconde référence est introduite
vers la moitié du paragraphe, ce qui donne
un peu l’impression de deux paragraphes
en un.
Je te l’ai déjà dit, je ne vais pas te
harceler avec ça, mais plusieurs références
dans un même paragraphe, c’est une mauvaise
idée.
Bon, malgré ces 2 défauts, ça passe quand
même parce que le collage de l’introduction
partielle au paragraphe donne l’impression
que la référence est plus éloignée - ça
c’est pour le premier défaut ;
et pour le second défaut, aucun titre n’est
souligné pour la première référence, donc
en lisant vite on peut avoir l’impression
qu’il n’y en a qu’une seule.
Ce premier paragraphe est donc, tout compte
fait, plutôt efficace grâce aux qualités
profondes, toujours les mêmes, du travail
de Fanny.
Je passe au suivant.
Dans le deuxième paragraphe, Fanny combine
un court passage du manuel 50 paragraphes
tout cuits (la référence à Noam Chomsky)
avec un autre passage (la référence à Ralph
Keyes) qu’elle a préparé elle-même.
Le paragraphe est globalement réussi :
un argument efficacement exposé dans la première
phrase : « Ensuite, la capacité qu’ont
certains orateurs à faire parler un texte,
à galvaniser autrui lors de sa lecture, crée
un danger d’assujettissement pour l’auditoire.
»
- là il y a une petite faute d’orthographe
que le correcteur a oubliée, il y a 2 T à
assujettissement -
Le paragraphe est également réussi
parce que sa structure, calquée sur les paragraphes
du manuel, et comme dans le reste de la copie,
facilite la lecture - d’ailleurs Fanny ne
se prend pas la tête pour l’introduire
en commençant par « Ensuite » -
Il est aussi bourré de liens logiques ; on
trouve 3 occurrences de « faire parler un
texte » pour montrer qu’on est bien dans
le sujet ; l'expression écrite toujours très
claire ; et le paragraphe se referme avec
une conclusion partielle.
Sur le plan de ma méthode des paragraphes,
Fanny customise bien les passages qu’elle
a empruntés pour les faire correspondre à
son argument.
Elle le fait, par exemple, en ajoutant « en
donnant vie à leur discours », qui renvoie
à l’expression de l’énoncé.
En dernière instance, cet avant-dernier paragraphe
me déçoit quand même à 2 égards :
comme dans le précédent, la première référence
est introduite beaucoup trop tôt (à la deuxième
phrase) ;
et puis on retrouve une fois de plus deux
références.
Mais encore une fois, Fanny réussit tout
de même à « faire passer la pilule » grâce
à son style, simple et clair, qui produit
une bonne impression de cohérence.
Allez, je passe au tout dernier paragraphe
du développement.
Dans ce paragraphe, Fanny utilise deux références
du manuel 50 paragraphes tout cuits (les paragraphes
n°53 et 22).
Plutôt court, et peut-être même trop - parce
qu’il ne fait que quatre phrases, quand
même - ce paragraphe a un peu les qualités
et les défauts des précédents.
Fanny est fidèle à la méthode des paragraphes,
et son style est toujours aussi bon : elle
expose efficacement l’argument, encore une
fois sans se prendre la tête pour l’introduire,
avec l’adverbe « Finalement » :
« Finalement se pose la question de l’étendue
de cette capacité à faire parler un texte.
»
Dans le paragraphe, elle reprend quatre fois
l’expression de l’énoncé ; elle dynamise
l’expression avec des questions - pourquoi
pas, même si je trouve que c’est plutôt
compliqué à faire.
Étant donné que c’est le tout dernier
paragraphe de la dissertation, juste avant
la conclusion, elle ne s’est pas embêtée
à écrire une conclusion partielle – et
elle a raison.
Malgré ces qualités, le paragraphe est un
peu faible à 3 égards :
tout d’abord, Fanny fait simplement allusion
aux deux références, elle ne les développe
pas du tout - c’est donc encore du name
dropping ;
ensuite, encore une fois, presque comme dans
toute la copie, elle combine encore deux références
;
et enfin, par rapport aux paragraphes précédents,
le fond est plus léger (mais bon je ne suis
pas censé parler du thème).
En clair, ce tout dernier paragraphe n’est
pas super, et il témoigne même, je trouve,
d’une certaine précipitation.
En conclusion,
cette troisième grande partie
aurait pu être meilleure.
Sur l’échelle de la qualité,
je trouve qu’elle est
entre la première
et la deuxième.
Les trois erreurs de cette grande partie
que tu ne dois pas reproduire,
ce sont
(je te les donne toujours
par ordre d’importance décroissante) :
un,
introduire la référence trop tôt
- essaie de le faire au minimum
à la troisième ou quatrième
phrase du paragraphe ;
deux,
le name dropping
- ça je t’en ai déjà parlé ;
troisième erreur :
j’en ai déjà parlé aussi,
parce que Fanny l’a fait dans toute sa copie,
c’est combiner deux références
dans un même paragraphe.
Après,
les trois points positifs sont les mêmes
que pour les grands un et deux :
la pertinence,
la clarté du style,
et la structure argumentative.
Avec cette troisième grande partie,
Fanny se rattrape un peu
par rapport à la deuxième,
mais je reste quand même sur ma faim,
parce que le grand un
laissait espérer une super copie.
Allez,
c’est l’heure de mettre une note !
Alors,
quels sont,
en synthèse,
les qualités et les défauts principaux
de la copie ?
Pour moi,
Fanny a réussi trois choses :
sa dissertation est pertinente,
c’est-à-dire qu'elle répond
très précisément au sujet ;
son style est très très clair ;
et enfin,
son argumentation
est structurée
très efficacement,
c’est-à-dire qu’en lisant la copie,
on comprend toujours pourquoi
telle idée est exposée à tel moment,
et on comprend bien
sa relation avec l’idée précédente.
Bien sûr,
et tu l’as bien vu
dans mon commentaire,
Fanny a aussi raté des choses.
Les trois défauts principaux de sa copie
ce sont
(je te les donne,
comme d’habitude,
par ordre d’importance décroissante) :
la problématisation est ratée
(dans l’introduction)
- on ne comprend pas
comment elle y arrive,
et puis ça n’était pas ça
le problème général posé par le sujet
-
deuxième défaut principal :
eh bien,
comme la problématisation est ratée,
le plan, même s’il est clair,
n’est pas terrible
- je ne sais pas si tu te souviens,
mais le test de pertinence
n’était pas concluant.
enfin,
troisième défaut :
les deuxième
et troisième grandes parties
laissent à désirer
(surtout la deuxième,
avec son troisième paragraphe « avorton
»).
Bon,
maintenant qu’on connaît
les trois qualités et défauts principaux
de la dissertation de Fanny,
je peux me mettre à la place du correcteur
:
quelle note cette copie
mérite-t-elle ?
Je te l’ai déjà dit,
on ne peut pas lui mettre
entre dix-huit et vingt,
surtout à cause du grand deux,
et puis aussi de la problématisation.
Après,
ses trois qualités principales,
la pertinence,
la clarté de l’expression,
et la structuration de l’argumentation
- ces trois qualités sont si précieuses
que c’est impossible de noter la copie
en-dessous du seuil d’admissibilité,
qui est à quatorze à HEC.
En conclusion,
la fourchette de notation qui serait juste,
ça serait entre quatorze
et dix-sept
- c’est-à-dire que si Fanny
avait eu quatorze,
quinze
ou seize,
elle ne pourrait pas se plaindre.
Maintenant,
la question c’est :
pourquoi dix-sept ?
Déjà,
moi je trouve que
quatorze ou quinze,
ça serait un peu injuste
tant la copie de Fanny sort du lot
par la pertinence
et la clarté générale du propos.
Et puis,
comme dans les très bonnes copies,
il y a très peu de fautes d’orthographes
- je n’en ai trouvées que deux ou trois
sur dix pages,
et ça,
ça invite vraiment à tirer la note
vers le haut.
Donc,
en dernière instance,
la copie de Fanny me semble mériter
seize ou dix-sept
- je tombe d’accord avec le correcteur.
Maintenant,
que dois-tu retenir de ce commentaire ?
Je pense qu’il y a
trois dimensions fondamentales
du travail de Fanny
dont tu as intérêt à t’inspirer
(et là,
je vais te les donner
par ordre d’importance
CROISSANTE,
donc prête bien attention
à la troisième dimension) :
la première dimension fondamentale,
c’est que Fanny est très pragmatique :
elle sait quel est l’enjeu
d’une épreuve de dissertation ;
elle se contente de traiter le sujet,
et uniquement le sujet,
avec une méthodologie éprouvée ;
deuxième dimension fondamentale
de la réussite de Fanny :
elle n’écrit pas comme Proust,
mais son style est très clair,
comme celui de mes paragraphes,
et ce style est très agréable à lire
pour le correcteur,
parce qu'il n’a jamais à s’arrêter
pendant sa lecture
pour s’interroger
sur le véritable sens d’une phrase
- cette dimension peut expliquer
À ELLE SEULE
le saut,
en termes de note,
de douze à dix-sept.
Bah oui,
tu écris
POUR LE CORRECTEUR
- donc si tu rends sa lecture moins pénible,
ça se traduira très favorablement
dans ta note.
Je te le répète :
la clarté du style
est survalorisée aux concours
- et pas qu’aux concours d’ailleurs,
mais aussi dans le monde professionnel,
et de manière générale dans la société,
parce qu’une expression claire
améliore la transmission de l’information
- la clarté de l’expression a donc
une valeur sociale importante.
Bon,
je ne vais pas digresser sur ce point,
je passe à la dimension la plus importante
du travail de Fanny :
la SIMPLICITÉ.
C’est cette dimension fondamentale qui,
à mes yeux,
fait de la copie de Fanny
un véritable modèle pour toi.
Contrairement à la majorité
des élèves de Prépa HEC,
Fanny ne s’est pas encombrée l’esprit
avec mille et un détails ;
elle s’en est tenue
aux choses simples.
elle ne s’est pas pris la tête,
elle n’a pas perdu de temps
à essayer de faire des transitions littéraires,
elle a juste suivi un modèle élémentaire
;
elle n’a pas raffiné l’introduction de
ses arguments
et de ses grandes parties,
elle a quasiment toujours repris la même
trilogie
« Premièrement…
ensuite…
enfin »
- c’est sûr que c’est très simple,
mais au moins on comprend très bien -
et enfin,
surtout,
Fanny ne s’est pas pris la tête
pour rédiger le développement,
elle a simplement appliqué rigoureusement
ma méthode des paragraphes,
et elle a librement
et intelligemment utilisé
les paragraphes du manuel
et ceux qu’elle avait préparés.
Si tu veux toi aussi
appliquer ma méthode des paragraphes
pour réussir à produire
aux concours,
SANS TE PRENDRE LA TÊTE,
une dissertation de culture générale
qui séduise le correcteur par sa clarté,
j’ai créé une formation en ligne
dans laquelle je t’apprends
comment faire
dans les moindres détails.
Tu peux en savoir plus
soit en cliquant sur le lien
qui apparaît en haut à droite de la vidéo,
soit sur celui qui est dans la description.
Dans cette formation,
je t’expliquerai en détail,
étape par étape,
comment
élaborer ta stratégie
avec ma méthode des paragraphes
et planifier intelligemment ton travail ;
comment préparer
ton stock de paragraphes ;
comment créer tes propres paragraphes,
comme l’a fait Fanny ;
comment apprendre efficacement
tes paragraphes ;
et enfin,
la phase cruciale,
pour laquelle je vais
encore plus dans le détail,
je vais t’apprendre
à utiliser tes paragraphes en dissertation.
Voilà le programme de la formation :
si ça t’intéresse,
tu peux en savoir plus
soit en cliquant sur le lien
qui apparaît en haut à droite de la vidéo,
soit sur celui qui est dans la description.
Alors,
tu peux aussi très bien t’en sortir
avec ma méthode des paragraphes
sans cette formation,
uniquement avec les deux manuels ;
mais si tu veux tirer le maximum
de ma méthode des paragraphes,
ça sera beaucoup plus facile
et plus rapide
- parce que ça te prendra beaucoup plus de
temps
si tu veux appliquer la méthode par toi-même
-
donc si tu veux tirer le maximum de la méthode
et économiser du temps
- du temps que tu utiliseras
pour devenir meilleur en maths,
en géopo ou en économie -
pour ça,
la formation à la méthode des paragraphes
est la meilleure solution.
Je te laisse donc
aller voir la page de présentation
si ça t’intéresse,
et je vais conclure cette vidéo.
Ce que je veux te dire pour terminer,
c’est que si a Fanny a réussi
alors qu’elle était seulement partie
pour « éviter le pire en philo »,
c’est parce qu’elle a choisi
les solutions les plus simples ;
c’est parce qu’elle s’est libérée
de tous les détails,
qu’elle a assuré l’essentiel en dissertation
:
mener une réflexion pertinente,
et s’exprimer clairement.
Voilà,
j’en ai terminé.
Si tu as des questions,
ça se passe dans les commentaires.
Et je te souhaite
bon courage pour le travail.